Clinton: and I paste it in
wherever I want.
Refresh, and we're already live.
Now, even a small--thank you.
[applause]
Now, even a small site like this
one can benefit from search.
I can do that with the Google
Custom Search element.
I'll go
to google.com/webelements,
click the
"Custom Search" element,
and right now I don't need
to do anything more.
The Custom Search element will
automatically configure itself
to search just
the content of my site.
So all I have to do is copy--
and I think you're
seeing the pattern here--
paste,
and the search box appears.
I'm going to do a test search.
Looks good.
However, since
the Custom Search element
is built on top
of the Ajax search APIs,
I can apply the styling rules
and custom JavaScript
however I like
to make it fit my site.
I move the search box over here,
and there we go.
So I've added maps,
news, and search
all in about three minutes.
And my site's
certainly more dynamic,
but I'd like to make it
more interactive.
I'd like to make it social.
I can do that with
the Google Conversation element.
The Google Conversation element
allows visitors to my site
to post comments and videos
and hold a conversation
about whatever topic I choose.
So, in fact, I will choose
Google I/O as a topic.
And I will copy the code,
I will paste it into the site,
and I will refresh.
And our conversation is live.
Hello, Google--
Oops.
Google I/O.
So we've seen,
just using copy and paste,
adding search, news, maps,
and conversations to the website
thanks to Google Web Elements.
Google Web Elements
are available today
at google.com/webelements.
Thank you.
Thank you, Vic.
[applause]
Gundrota:
Copy/paste development.
We think that's really
going to make it easier.
Next I'd like to talk
about Android.
Eric mentioned it
in his opening remarks.
We couldn't be happier with
the progress that we've made
in a little over
just half a year
since Android's been introduced.
In those brief, few months,
we've had three versions out,
including the latest
version last week
of the Android 1.5 SDK.
We've had ten carriers and--
available in over 12 countries.
Over 4,900 apps--
almost 5,000 apps,
including apps like the one we
demonstrated on Android earlier,
using the powerful capability
of its browser.
And on average we're
seeing users of Android
download over 40 apps
to their device.
And so the ecosystem
is really working,
browser share is just
fantastic and fun to watch,
and we thank you
for your support.
What we'd like
to do next, though,
is show you a sneak peek into
what's coming next on Android,
and for that I'd like
to invite up Romain Guy.
Romain, please, why don't you
show us what's coming next.
Guy: Thank you, Vic.
[applause]
With Android 1.5 now live,
the Android team is already
hard at work on the next
version of Android,
and we code named it "Donut."
You may have heard of it
on the Web already.
And today I want to show you
two exciting, new features
that will ship
as part of Donut.
First, we want to make search
more useful and more powerful
both for users
and developers alike.
For users, we want--
we want them to be able,
from a single query,
to be able to search the Web,
their contacts, their bookmarks,
their application,
and their music.
But let me show you
what it looks like.
So here I have
an Android device.
And on my home screen,
when I click the search widget,
I can initiate a new search.
And if I start typing,
the device
automatically looks
for my applications
or my contacts.
We can also
look for Web results.
So if we're hungry for pizza,
and the 3G is working,
we can
search the Web for that.
But we decided
that the search UI
could be a lot more than that.
The search UI can also act
as a brand-new launcher
for you as a user.
Every time I click
a search result,
the system remembers what I did
with that search result,
and the more I use my device,
the more the--the--
the device will know about me,
about what I do every day,
about my common tasks.
And what happens is every time
I start a new search,
I get pre-populated results.
So here, for instance,
last time I did a search
I clicked the calendar
application.
And I see here the result
that matters to me
on a day-to-day basis.
So this is going to be
an awesome feature
'cause I know that
in this part of the UI
I will always have
access to the thing
that matters to me as a user.
But there's more.
We want the search UI
to become a powerful tool
for your applications.
And with just
a few lines of code,
your application can populate
more results in the search UI.
And I have a simple
example here.
I wrote an application
for myself,
just a list of books I've read,
and I wanted to be able
to quickly search
my library from the home screen.
So with just
a couple lines of XML,
I am now able to add
my search results to this UI.
And if I type the name
of one of my favorite authors,
I can see his books
appearing in my search UI.
And you can see
search results from the Web--
more books
and more Web results.
So we're really excited
about this feature
because you guys
are creating the content.
You have the application,
you have content
that the Android platform
doesn't have,
and we can't wait to see
what you're going to do with it
and what you're going
to put in this UI.
Next, we wanted
to add a new API--
something that you developers
have widely requested.
In Android 1.5, we introduced
a new speech recognition API
that lets you
control the device
without any
physical interaction.
Now, the problem is the device
cannot interact with you.
So we're introducing
a new Text-to-Speech API
that lets the device,
you know, read text to you,
or give you a result,
or, you know,
turn-by-turn navigation
if you're writing
a GPS application.
And I have a simple demo here.
We modified
the Translate application
that you can find
on the Android market,
and we added
the Text-to-Speech API.
So, for instance, here, if I
want to translate a sentence
from English to French, and I
click the "Translate" button...
computer voice: Bienvenue
a San Francisco.
Guy: The device reads
the sentence to me.
And we're shipping--
we're going to ship Donut
with several voice packs
for different languages,
so in any language the user
will get the right accent
so they will be able
to understand
what the device
is saying perfectly.
So, for instance, in German...
computer voice: Willkommen
in San Francisco.
Guy: Or even in English.
As I--as you can see,
we have two different
versions in English.
computer voice: Welcome
to San Francisco.
Guy: So we're really excited...
[applause]
We're really excited
about these APIs
'cause we know that you guys
are going to do
great things with it.
But it gets even better.
We're shipping a new
text-to-speech API in Donut,
but we're also going to ship
the text-to-speech engine,
and thanks to SVOX,
that engine will be open source.
So as part of
the Android platform,
any Android device
will have an open-source
text-to-speech engine
of high quality
like you just heard right now.
Finally, I want to show you
a small experiment
that we've been working on
in the Android team.
We--you know,
we recognize that sometimes
finding a specific item
in a long list of data--
for instance, I have
several hundred contacts--
and finding one item
in that list
can be, you know,
pretty painful.
So we have different solutions
to address that issue.
We have search,
we have search
on the home screen,
you can filter your list
when you're
in a contact application,
we have a fast scroll widget--
many different ways to do it.
But we wanted something new,
something more interesting
and that was
a little more fun to use.
So I have a small demo
for you here.
Wouldn't it be cool if I could
just launch
my contact application
and start drawing on the screen
to filter my list?
And I keep--
and I can keep going,
and the device just
recognizes the handwriting
and filters the list.
Instead of filtering,
if you prefer,
you can simply jump to an item.
So, for instance,
in the music application,
I can jump directly to a certain
position in the list.
We care about
the user experience,
but we also care
about the developer experience.
And we hope that
with those new APIs
that we're
introducing in Donut
there will be more--
you are going to come up
with awesome applications
that will make Android
a more exciting platform.
Thank you, Vic.
Gundrota: Thank you very much,
Romain, thank you.
[applause]
Well, folks, we covered
quite a bit of ground.
First of all, you heard about
our call to action for HTML--
Google's commitment
to make applications
that are HTML 5 exploitative,
and we hope you join us.
We talked about App Engine
being opened up
for Java sign-ups.
We gave you a sneak peek at GWT
and what's coming next--
in the next version there.
We introduced
Google Web Elements--
copy/paste development.
And finally, we gave you
a sneak peek
at what's coming next
in Android.
We have three more things
and one final spot.